raphaël we're here at MCM Expo it's
great to have you here obviously you
Caden in Mass Effect is super popular
why do you think that is you know King
character is particularly for women and
certain men provides a sort of a very
romantic play through the game there's a
lot of men who come to me and tell me I
hate to tell you but I killed you in
virmire and okay dude it's okay but I do
know that that he's very loyal and very
you know passionate and caring and sort
of a conscience I guess there's certain
scents and a good man and and you know
for whatever combination of reasons they
have been able to sort of create this
extraordinary universe that has so much
depth in it and has people so connected
to these characters I mean of all the
things that are done you know in terms
of kind of fan sort of response I have
to say the mass effect is the most
extraordinary sort of response barn on
thinking about these recording sessions
that you've done what particular
memorable moments have you had from them
Oh memorable moments I mean you know
we've done these games now for over what
almost 10 years right so so you know the
the wonderful things that are really fun
or just you know I always loved the
scenes that were really I mean look let
me back up it's a second and say this a
lot of video games unlike what they did
with Mass Effect are from a from an
acting point of view anyway all about -
screaming screaming and yelling get down
look out sure you know and and
invariably if you talk to any of the
actors who do them you'll find that they
talk about how their voice turns into
hamburger afterwards you can't talk for
three days you know you're wiped out
because they just want it louder louder
louder scream more and and and what was
so really cool about as a fact
whatever's came along was that it was a
game that was really devoted to
characters and relationships and not
just screaming and and they made a very
specific point of saying hey this is we
went
more like an episode of 24 we went to
more like a movie we want a film a
performance we don't want to just sort
of be either just characters or cartoony
we want it real so that was what was
sort of so engaging and really sort of
took you know I think took this game
into sort of making something special I
understand also anecdotally it's the
game that really definitively brought in
more women in the gaming than any other
game and I was told and again I think
because of these relationships because
of these scenes you know where you know
you could you knew I mean between
Shepard and and Caden where there's this
sort of undercurrent or subtext of
something that wants to be said but
can't
those are great scenes to play now you
mentioned movie that it was more like a
movie and that got me thinking well
there has been talk of Mass Effect movie
hasn't there what's your take on that
and who do you like to see it's direct
if you could have anybody oh my god well
I mean it's genius idea of course
because they've got this great fan base
and you know Marc Mero was just talking
about how it's essentially the gaming
worlds version of Star Wars right I mean
in terms of the it's sort of its depth
and breadth and sighs you know the God
who could direct it I mean it's just
there you know it's gonna be a enormous
movie and they'll spend a zillion
dollars on it when they do it and and
you know all the biggest you know movie
stars will be in it and and those of us
who created the parts will be waving
from the audience I'm sure maybe we'll
do a cameo but but but at the end of the
day it's a it's a great idea because
it's just it's such a great world I
think you've got you've got an immediate
fan base who which I think would really
stick it out you guys have someone else
but in cadence boots who would it be do
you think who do you like to see on the
big screen
Kali I have no idea I mean I guess hmm
who would you think I don't know oh my
god this is turning the question back on
me it's you hard
it's so funny I I told this story there
was a panel recently we just did and you
know I met the fellow who's the face
model for Kaidan Alenko and he's a
wonderful guy and we went to we went to
went to lunch together and we were you
know we both were on nonprofits and so
we were talking about you know our
background and and then so he said we
had to get a picture I was like yeah and
so it was a guy sitting in a cafe and he
said he was geeky wicked guy that you
know hat and he was on his phone and I
said excuse me would you mind taking our
picture and I seize it
yeah oh yeah I said you know I do the
voice and he does the he's the face of
this game we do is for something ever
met and he said oh yeah what games in
some sort of indie games kind of indie I
said you know best fact II went yeah I
said you know Kaidan Alenko he went oh
my god I need this my Facebook page so I
mean you guys are everywhere right so
it's it's I think you know I think a
movie will be in order
and I think I think it'll be pretty
exciting to see so what about castings
comes down and what about um once upon a
time as long as he played two characters
in that which me must be quite a quite
interesting view as an actor as well and
I know that you've talked about wanting
or would like a cross over between once
upon a time and star wars now that was
he Disney's got ABC and the Star Wars
franchise and what do you think that
would look like you know I said that in
jest honestly just because I know Disney
but you know Disney bought Star Wars and
and they're saying what characters let's
start Doody to happen let's make it
happen you heard it here first
yeah I mean I don't know it's it's they
can go anywhere I don't know if that
would really work I don't really seem
that it was sort of a gag actually
better be pretty freaking find the
character you like in the show if you
could have that happen one of the
characters I mean this is some of the
wonderful literary characters now that
they introduced Frankenstein I mean you
know Moby Dick could be interesting or
you know
oh god there's just so many I mean it's
really amazing to have a show that
literally could go anywhere you know
it's somebody think about you know how
most shows get locked in to you know the
case of the week or the body of the week
or the you know the bad guy of the week
whatever this is a this has so much
depth and breadth and and and such an
enormous canvas it's such a testament to
what they've done and and and for
American entertainment which doesn't
always travel well to other countries
this also has seemingly a way to kind of
cut across so many boundaries I mean I
get tweets from literally all over the
world and people who really just love
these stories love these sort of
familiar fairytales and love the
retelling and now we only thinking about
crossovers with Star Wars and one time I
want to know I want to know what
character you'd like to be in Star Wars
Star Wars Episode seven who would you be
JJ Abrams listen in c-3po fil if you got
anything you'd like to say to the fans
of both and once upon a time and also
Mass Effect of course out there as well
yeah she was I mean for the mass spec
fans we've you know I think I'll feel
sort of sad about the fact that it's
come to an end but it also has created
sort of a really remarkable precious
this of an experience of this epic
journey and you know in a way we can
always say we'll always have Mass Effect
and the world we shared and to to once
upon a time in terms of kind of what's
ahead it's you know thrilling to sort of
see where they're gonna go I think the
possibilities are endless and for anyone
who wants to follow me on Twitter its
Raphael Sbarge
you know I love hearing from the fans
and I love hearing what you have to say
and what your thoughts are and there was
a new poll as to you know who who's
gonna take over the positions of mayor
and you know in Storybrooke now so
anyway it's pretty fun chat going on
anyway so yeah come funny
you